the family of Lisa Marie Presley is
prepping for a public Memorial you're
the only people that can bring me out of
my house
fans and family will say their final
goodbye Sunday at 9am on the front lawn
of Graceland her final resting place
Lisa Marie's three daughters and Mom
Priscilla tell ET they are grateful for
the support well wishes and outpouring
of love but is a fight Brewing over the
estate when it's no longer mine it with
my children's you know that's that Lisa
Marie told us her three daughters will
inherit Graceland but there's a lot at
stake especially since the tourist
attraction could generate as much as 110
million dollars a year and according to
reports a custody battle over the 14
year old twins may be Brewing Finley's
Mommy's girl Harper's Daddy's girl the
girl's dad Michael Lockwood spent the
last six years fighting with Lisa Marie
for custody during that time she even
falsely accused him of possessing child
pornography a source close to Lockwood
tells E.T as of now he has full custody
and will do whatever he has to do to
protect it I don't think that there are
any concerns at this time with his
physical fitness and well-being like
there were early on in the separation if
there is going to be a dispute this may
end up in the courts potentially
entering that fight first husband Danny
Keough who was living with Lisa Marie
and the twins at the time of her death
he reportedly considers himself their
stepfather he's got so much integrity
and he's also my best friend what do
they call you Nona
there's their Nona Priscilla who raised
Harper and Finley when her daughter
First lost custody but don't discount
Lisa Marie's eldest 33 year old Riley
She's So level-headed and she's much
further advanced than I ever was the
twins are now 14 years old they have
preferences in terms of where they want
to go to school who they want to live
with so the court is definitely going to
honor that you know something goes down
the Harper will want Daddy and if
something goes down with Finley she
wants meat they get along really well